before their deaths the following actors
didn't just make their marks as some of
marvel's most popular or interesting
characters
they left behind impressive bodies of
work with hollywood being all the better
for their contributions
these stars weren't just marvel
favorites they built some of hollywood's
most
distinguished careers miguel ferreira
comes from
a major show business family his cousin
was superstar george clooney and his
parents were oscar winner jose ferreira
and 50s pop star rosemary clooney david
lynch fans remember ferrer as the
opinionated fbi agent
albert rosenfield on twin peaks ferrer
also co-starred in the 1994 adaptation
of stephen king's the stand
playing randall flag's right-hand man
lloyd henry
apart from his dozens of other tv guest
star roles ferreira made memorable
appearances
in films including traffic hotshots part
do
and robocop but observant marvel
cinematic universe fans will remember
him for his brief but
important part in iron man 3. in the
final entry of the trilogy ferrer played
rodriguez the corrupt mandarin connected
vice president of the united states who
tries to help assassinate president
matthew ellis
sadly in january 2017 ferrer died of
cancer-related complications
at the age of 61. when stand-up comedy
boomed in the 1980s
and early 1990s tons of clubs popped up
in cities
cable networks filled out their
programming day with shows like an
evening at the improv and the hbo comedy
half hour
and a ton of joke tellers became
instantly famous
among them was john pinette a gifted
stand-up and impressionist
pinette dedicated a lot of his act to
making fun of
himself he toured and taped comedy
specials extensively while also landing
acting roles
after playing a high school coach on
parker lewis can't lose he appeared on
seinfeld dr katz professional therapist
and in 2004 he showed up as bumpo in the
ultra-violent film adaptation of the
ultra-violent revenge comic the punisher
opposite thomas jane
panette brought comic relief to the
otherwise dark movie as the easy-going
character and the financial beneficiary
of the punisher's crusade
tragically in 2014 pinette was found
dead in a pittsburgh hotel room
and a medical examiner ruled that he'd
passed as a result of
natural causes pinette was only 50.
in 1969 peter fonda produced and starred
in the hippie
and counterculture classic biker movie
easy rider for which he received his
first of two academy award nominations
the second came for 1997's yuli's gold
in which fonda starred as a grieving
beekeeper with a troubled family in
between
fonda appeared in dozens of well-known
movies including the last movie the
cannonball run
and escape from la fonda's role in ghost
rider as mephistopheles was among the
last in a long
legendary career
far out in 2007
actor and avid comic book fan nick cage
got his superhero franchise going with
two ghost rider movies cage played
johnny blaze
a bounty hunter forced into service for
the unholy demon played by fonda
in 2019 fonda passed away at age 79
due to lung cancer just before 2010
irfan khan got acting gigs in popular
and acclaimed american and british films
he played a police detective in the
oscar-nominated slumdog millionaire
and he portrayed the adult version of
main character pai patel
recalling his survival of a shipwreck in
the oscar-nominated life of pi
khan showed up as dinosaur park owner
simon masrani in jurassic world and he
also played the villainous provost in
inferno fans of andrew garfield's peter
parker will also recognize khan from the
amazing spider-man where he played oz
corp executive and scientist
dr rajit ratha as a prolific television
actor khan broke through to the a-list
of indian cinema in the 2000s and won
numerous accolades for his work in life
in a metro
hasil and pon singh tamar which won him
a national film award for best actor
shockingly in 2018
khan announced that he'd been diagnosed
with a neuroendocrine tumor
following a hospitalization in mumbai
for an infection in 2020 the superstar
died
at age 53 in 2008 iron man became the
first
marvel cinematic universe entry but the
modern history of movies based on marvel
comics characters goes back to 1986 with
the critically reviled box office flop
howard the duck protagonist howard is
involved in everything sci-fi
including the cosmos itself personified
and voiced by veteran actor richard
kiley
the cosmos countless
worlds upon worlds
kylie was a decorated actor appearing in
shows like hawaii 5-0 and colombo and
won four
emmy awards and two tony awards
including one for man of la mancha
kylie died in march 1999 of a blood
disorder
he was 76 years old as one of film
and tv's most prolific intense and
versatile character actors it's hard to
say exactly which role is the one for
which
reggie kathy is best known it might be
warden martin kearns on the harrowing
prison drama oz
or political organizer norman wilson on
the wire or
barbecue joint proprietor freddie hayes
on house of cards
which won kathy an emmy award for
outstanding guest actor in a drama
series
kathy also played more than one role in
multiple marvel franchises
in the 2015 fantastic four reboot he
portrayed dr
franklin storm father of superheroes sue
and johnny storm
kathy also starred in netflix marvel
cinematic universe
adjacent series luke cage in the role of
james lucas a pastor
and the father of luke in february 2018
kathy died at his new york city home
from lung cancer according to the new
york times
kathy was 59. dr wesley von spears
appeared briefly in both guardians of
the galaxy films
he didn't have any lines but he was
memorable just the same because von
spears is a dog
in guardians of the galaxy the pup
portrayed holographic dog
and in guardians of the galaxy volume 2
he played the part of
dog in the back of truck at dairy queen
landing a role in hollywood is sometimes
about who you know
and nepotism definitely played a part in
von spears casting since he was the pet
of guardian's writer director james gunn
the dog's influence on marvel movies
comprises more than just a couple of
cameos
gunn told io9 truthfully a lot of groot
is based on my dog von spears
i think there's a sort of puppy-like
innocence to groot that if my dog could
talk
it would probably say i am groot dr
wesley von spears died at age 17 in
february 2020.
gunn briefly delayed filming on his next
film the suicide squad to fly home and
be with his dog in his final moments
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you